non voilà j'ai pour toute suite utile
qu'à sa poêlée or notre vidéo c'est faut
rester là on est bien loin des
sauvegardes a su l'attend ça fait des
mois et des mois qu'on n'a pas fait des
vidéos sur ce g8 y avait une petite
nouveauté coup là on peut caser deux
personnes c'est parti nous dit
aujourd'hui ça va pas être de tout repos
mais avant de réunir nos deux
tourtereaux nous allons découvrir une
autre nouveauté ça à prendre cinq
secondes auparavant creusé un trou d'où
tu es quelqu'un avec une palme août le
quelqu'un dans le trou et reboucher le
trou et ce après moins de 7 secondes
[ __ ] c'est finalement la chose que tu
apprends à faire en premier avant tuer
des gens si les entrées pour cacher des
preuves mais bon je vous présente qu
kaunas nc et je vous présente notre
deuxième tourterelles jean michel rioux
cette femme est donc à son cours de
cuisine elle apprend à faire du 2 du jeu
parce que c'est lorsque je m'approche de
la porte qu'est ce que je découvre un
homme qui mériterait de passer 48 heures
en garde à vue pour harcèlement même l'a
compris ces deux jeunes gens sont
amoureux l'un de l'autre mais ils ne
savent pas encore et on va devoir les
relier par les liens sacrés je suis
prêtre ou sur youtube j'ai vu un truc
particulier aujourd'hui c'était un petit
chat qui marche et aux alentours de
l'école c'était une adorable qu'une
créature si tu dois quelque part est ce
que tu pourrais le prendre en photo pour
moi mais j'accepte avec grand plaisir
alors le petit chalet où hockey trouvé
on va le prendre en photo souvenir des
modistes parfait je sauvegarde range ton
cul au retour voire you will et la
[ __ ] le mec qui redonne couleurs c'est
un fantôme c'est un esprit ouais c'est
lui c'est le choc j'ai vu rôder qu'il
est en bonne santé
c'est super bien voulu de soudain chasse
pas très compliqué on va pa semi tota
écoles et on tombe sur quoi sur un chat
à l'école c'est parfait et sur ta blague
du sur google on tombe sur ce morceau de
la vidéo x alors maintenant les amis on
va rendre service à l'autre tourterelles
[ __ ] il rend pas les choses faciles
elle partie où la limite on coule
bonjour coco n'a pu jeter en un service
or mon iphone va pas bien il me sert
trop autour de la poitrine
j'aimerais avoir de l'uniforme mais je
ne peux pas me normand procurer à
maintenant je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
quoi se plaindre c'est pas comme si
quelqu'un pouvait faire quelque chose
fait le sale [ __ ] tu pas soin de ton
code mais est-ce qu'on connait pas un
gros pervers qui peut nous avoir plein
de choses en échange au fond de culotte
mais si je vais en uniforme
il faut prendre cinq buts en culotte en
photo ça va durer six secondes on y va
[Musique]
maintenant qu'on a nos culottes qu'est
ce qu'on va faire on va fuir avant
qu'elle nous pète la gueule des gens
mais on va surtout commandé auprès de
cet homme un uniforme un casque avec
micro pour game et auxquelles m avec ta
team sur le road show on a donc
l'uniforme et le casque mais est-ce que
l'uniforme va bien qu'aucun acnc non on
va modifier l'uniforme pour le rendre un
peu comme ça c'est fait on retourne voir
que connaît et on lui dit tiens et fdp
parle-moi mieux je suis pas ton esclave
mais dans le doubs chic comme chopin en
uniforme et je suis pas dans les siens
le conages te présente son nouvel
uniforme n'y a pas moyen c'est une forme
va exactement parfaitement seulement
dire je suis enfin en tout confort tu es
plus j'arrive pas trait dessus comme ça
j'ai pas le temps laissé le temps à
observer les fatiguer donc ça c'est fait
bien là mon avis on va lui parler ou à
lui dire mais qu il ya une meuf elle est
sur toi elle s'appelle coco n'a haruka à
ta place j'irais au sérieux ouais je la
kiffe
c'est fantastique maintenant qu'on sait
que l'huile là qui font mal et voir coco
n'a pour savoir si elle quelqu'un veut
te rencontrer à la fontaine est je pense
que c'est au genre de mec
ok j'y vais maintenant elle est à la
fontaine s dépêche toi oh regardez comme
c'est beau un homme qui rejoint l'amour
de sa vie la future mère de ses enfants
ok maintenant que tout est prêt juste à
médéa cet arbre je suis pas là pour te
conseille mais sa petite oreillette
ambiance posée tamisée on est finalement
à sa place et on doit faire plaisir à
coco now on peut faire des remarques
négatives sur divers sujets on peut
faire des remarques positives aux pôles
a complimenté peut lui offrir un cadeau
mais on a rien donc on va juste se
contenter aujourd'hui d'un compliment a
tenu tout va bien ça lui a plu la barre
à un petit peu augmenté et lorsqu'elle
arrivera après de soccer
telle une dague dans un coeur c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui je note aussi le petit
côté gentleman de cet homme qui salit
ses chaussures sur la pelouse humide
imprégné de la rosée du matin on va
dormir et demain on va devoir enquêter
sur que kaunas nc
et j'ai passé une bonne nuit moi pas
jeter sur des flics c'est déjà un
épisode je disais que c'était d'un
épisode et après je me couchais et du
coup je me secoue chez le spectateur
dirait un tweet d'un mec qui veut buzz
et mid caps été le moment le plus
agréable de dorian d'airé aujourd'hui
vous savez ce que c'est c'est d'aller en
cours qui l'aurait cru
personne maintenant on va aller trouver
qu connaît on va nous demander de nous
suivre et on va essayer de voir un petit
peu ce qu'elle aime et scalable club
occulta on a appris des opinions ou à
voir ses intérêts et on voit qu'elle
aime la bouffe et qu'elle n'aime pas ni
les objets contendants qui tuent des
gens ni le club au culte ça nous fait
déjà trois points je vais t'emmener à la
librairie est ce que tu aimes les hommes
qui étudient oui regardez ya des coeurs
qui sort de sa tête ça que je parle pas
du nombre de clics passe-partout trouve
en moyenne dans un épisode de fort
boyard mais je parle bel et bien du
nombre de points qu'on va voir au prix
de kokoda bon mec soit faire c'est
simple si tu aimes suivre on va
t'instruire un peu on va s'asseoir ici
on va étudier ensemble en dari china et
d'eric us omaha à étudier manon value
pimpé physiquement tu devrait adopter
des petites lunettes parce que ça plaît
énormément à ta future femme tu devrais
aussi de percer un petit peu partout
elle adore ça ne me demandez pas comment
je le sais j'ai enquêté où j'ai checké
sur youtube je sais pas et tu vas aussi
te lacs et les cheveux teulé cola
tombons crâne bien bombée c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui demain je veux qu'ils
viennent comme ça ces fausses infos en
oublie de la complimenter aujourd'hui
[ __ ] alors on a vu qu'elle n'aimait
pas tout ce qui était couteau un j'aime
pas les couteaux à moi non plus on a vu
qu'elle aimait tout ce qui était
nourriture aubin décidément on a
vraiment les mêmes opinions
ben voila c'était très rentable la barre
est presque à la moitié ça va le faire
après sept journées de travail qu'est ce
qui se passe on sait tous que coco naeem
n'aime pas elle aime l'argent tout les
mêmes ça voilà je peux faire une chaîne
youtube elle n'aime pas les jeux vidéo
au regard des normes y avait des
lunettes de piercings la coupe comme ça
écoute moi non plus j'aime pas les jeux
vidéo ah j'adore la tune un peu je suis
youtuber ça tombe bien
bon il nous reste deux jours pour que
cette barre soit 100% ça va le faire
aujourd'hui on va prendre une petite
rose qu'on va offrir harry ou non pas
qu'on l'ait mme mais on veut qu'ils
offrent à coco nawas et le programme
d'aujourd'hui way quelque 1,3 me contre
mon programme a fait choisir notre
colonne des bâtards on a le microphone
en place
oh oui oh là là j'aime pas du tout le
cas mot cool c'est trop bizarre ce
qu'ils font j'invoque sa tante lui soir
à l'été à une petite rose c'était
vraiment super de se parler j'espère
qu'on pourra se le faire de temps
j'espère qu'on pourra remettre
j'espère qu'on pourra romain vous avez
compris allez ça dégage demain c'est le
[ __ ] de jours gym
il court à la recherche du destin de sa
dulcinée la joie qu'on est bon la barre
est à fond on peut dire au revoir
tu dois y aller un c'est dommage
j'aurais tellement aimé passer plus de
temps avec toi je sais bien cherché mon
rêve c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est que elle
fasse ce qu'elle est censée faire c'est
à dire quand il sera 17h30 elle doit
mettre une lettre dans le casier de
reebok observons elle a fait on le met
au ralenti la au montage au regard des
hommes c'est la magie roger garcia
passait autour de moi je veux la lettre
date d'occasion et maintenant il faut
espérer que cet homme viennent chercher
comme par hasard un objet dans son
casier il arrive on va immortaliser ce
moment vas-y oui oui y'a rien si c'est
bon en fait tu connais la mine d'être
invité par par quelqu'un d'autre lui la
découpe c'est super super g sa part mon
dieu oh mon dieu ça y est en route vers
son destin dans la locomotive du bonheur
dans le rer c de l'agression bientôt
dans cette femme dans la joie un type de
trouver la femme qui partagera sa vie
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours vers cette
colline me portant le cerisier en fleurs
très belle métaphore par rapport à la
femme qui elle portera l'enfant l'enfant
présentant la survie de la flore
présentant les cheveux de l'enfant
attention cette incroyable ce qui se
passe il y va hélas hélas cancun a
rencontré rick ou sous le cerisier
quand on a lu à voix qu'elle avait
développé des sentiments envers lui et
qu'on lui dit que c'était réciproque et
qu'il regrettait un peu les boucles
d'oreilles et les cheveux roses là
qu'est tout connaît les coûts se
partagèrent attendre qui pendant que les
pétales de sueur aisée en fleurs tombe
et autour de [ __ ] une à la pole et
maintenant sans bande de puces ont tous
un par un mais ce pack de merde là sous
un arbre avec la lumière digne et si
jamais comme ça la vraie vie il pleut
déjà
et voilà je ne sais pas si je n'étais
pas là mais ça vous a plu ans se
trouvait dans une prochaine c'est ayant
des respirateurs et des autres 72
personnes ont regardé portez vous bien
tu recommences déception pis ça vient
[Musique]